Chris will be hosting ESPN special
postseason NFL countdown on Super Bowl
Sunday
ESPN's NFL primetime after the game and
an hour-long tribute Chris Berman he did
go all the way on Thursday February 2nd
well this is quite a swan song here of
Sir Alex it's not a complete hi dad
nitrogen the glasses look is really
doing it for my pulling you very very
you know very purpose Oriole as you say
I am wearing four Overman well then you
want to look into it we love you he
posted some great pictures from my high
school senior days I had a lot of hair I
was very envious I thank you for that
yeah well it's not a swan song per se
like I said it's Yogi Berra I'm leaving
but I'm staying but this the show that's
on fittingly groundhogs night by the way
when it went up with that I don't know
what's in it and I probably be the last
to see it because you know Super Bowl
week well I'll look at it in late
February and wonder did you really do
all that you know I think it'll be some
yuck you'll probably relive some of the
days yourself if you see it you'll I was
there then well I brought it up when the
fact that you stayed to do my first
SportsCenter and you called me the
Charlotte Observer you remember this
because I observed for a couple of
months I think that I was just there
watching you guys do SportsCenter and I
got to the point where I go I think I
got it down here and then they said all
right you're going to do your first
SportsCenter you had just done the 11
o'clock SportsCenter and you said I'll
stay and do the Sports Center with you
and that might have been I don't know if
there's a one o'clock or a two o'clock
but you were staying late and I never
forgot that it's one of the kindest
gestures that you ever did and you've
done an awful lot but you stayed and I
got the intimidation out of the way
because I did a show with you survived
and then I moved on from there you
caught me on a bad day I observed for
that what did you observe for too much
to smile okay mice now the ESPN I came
to one three weeks old yeah October 1st
79 was a little different than the s-pen
you came table one was just late 80s
like a nine okay so you're coming from
CNN you did the show you knew what you
were doing yeah so me I'm 24
I've been on TV and Hartford for three
months I started you're going to do the
overnight show at 3:00 a.m. you're going
to watch one night you're going to
explain it and tell me one night watch
what this guy does at the three a.m.
sign-off show and I came in October
second my second night uses well where
is Wayne Wayne Hagan that plays out here
you're doing the show I had a quick I
was the Charlotte glanced at her did you
almost not work in the SPN never come
there Romania way back then yeah well no
this Hartford TV was just a weekend
Saturday Sunday
you know $23 Saturday night and $23
Sunday night at the end European oil is
killing minimum wage pal yeah and no no
I applied to say we're just starting I
said I don't have a tape to said you
wanted to watch me but you knew nothing
about what it was I I knew it was
starting so I went over there not there
but there was some other place like late
August or early September - hey would
you consider me and then I got a phone
call could you I was working radio
during the week TV on the weekend in but
again for nothing would you like to do
our overnight our sign off at the time
show I'm making a combination maybe 10
they should pay is 16 where do I sign up
you know 3:00 a.m. I did that pretty
much for four years other than the
football it was okay was but also
traffic wasn't bad going home I'm
wondering if you came along ten years
later good question with that experience
never would've been hired I mean I had
already been on for three months but
really also your style okay
well interesting quite they would have
had to have decided before looking at
this let's say I was on local or
Hartford or somewhere TV for a few years
doing what I was doing I mean I don't
want to say I was Warner wolf but he was
certainly upbeat in that that did exist
just not yeah of course local sports
would be five minutes you want to kind
of do nicknames in the Seattle Mariners
if you're working in Connecticut you
know
they would have had to decide ahead of
time if this is for us or not me it was
Rahman I think he can speak in complete
sentences and we'll see how it goes
there was no blueprint for what you were
doing no no only no and there's no
blueprint and for the show a half-hour
sports Walter Cronkite only had a
half-hour
that's real news yeah if you think about
it so there's no blueprint for any of it
we really were wearing Houston mercury
astronauts
we went up circled around and hope we
came down in the ocean you know at what
point did you realize that ESPN was
going to make it well the easy answer
would be when we got the NFL contract
for eight Sunday night games they didn't
start to the World Series is over so
Halloween ish when we got that contract
in 87 early it exists as eight years by
that point you had a feeling before that
like we're going somewhere in cables
remember here at CNN cable from 1979 to
1989 was a skyrocket which no one could
have really predicted anyone to predict
that it was line you know okay and but
87 the NFL like why would Pete Rozelle
pretty smart guy know and trust
to quote cable eight games and then the
show called NFL primetime was hatched by
Pete Rozelle and then not yet our
president Steve borne Stein with me in
mind once we had that I knew we were on
the map to stay do you ever get in
trouble for something you said on here
there get brought in I mean I I'm saying
that I know I didn't Keith and I got in
a couple brought in a couple of times
and threatened with our jobs but I never
got to that I did for some reason
because you know I can talk like a
sailor if I need to there's there's
always been a kind of a stop sign now
we've all missed spoken on and there's
plenty stories of that but not to that I
got in trouble a couple times when I
showed up from a vacation with a must
okay so that's not but that's not you
can shave it and you're good
you know one time I did it because they
had forgotten this
trackdays - kind of okay it's been about
14 months as we've looked at what you're
making how about a little I can now say
this it's the 80s I kind of walked in
with Audia - and then by the end of that
conversation well while I'm in the
office you know it's been a year and oh
okay well so that was a good negotiating
ploy but no no not your job but you had
safety in numbers they were to you I was
kinda low Tommy meas and I never was a
different deal because I've mentioned
the late Tom nice tan because I did so
many late shows with him I mean and
11:30 and 2:30 we would do 10 a week
sometime yeah so no but we are yet but I
still have time to get better no you're
good tryst
we got called in we like how they hear
that I always maintain that if you go
into a room the more wood paneling in
the room the more trouble you're in
because there were there was paneling on
the roof that there was lots of Emmys
like it you knew you were going into a
room that you don't normally get to go
into and I just remember that our boss
at the time Bobby and started banging on
the desk and like Khrushchev and I I'm
thinking I got three little kids you
know like I can't lose this gig and I
remember that we were threatened with
our jobs and we walked out and I'm just
mortified like I him
deer-in-the-headlight and Oberman goes
epi' like a what that would be after FM
now you'll be my high school and that
would be him and he it brought us closer
together
we didn't care and we just said we're
going to do it our way as long as we can
continue to do it and but that was the
one moment where sort of injury because
they said and I've said this before and
I want to tell you this because I never
wanted to be construed as negative they
said we don't want another Berman
because they knew that you had got into
a status you would created you know you
had a brand before brands were popular
they were worried we were going to be
seceding from the union and that's why I
say then they go we don't want another
Burman and we're thinking why wouldn't
you want another Burman and
was that management took us to test they
should have been scared of any of it but
that's that's what you played nice
though you were good you were great team
player we have to be an actor every day
I don't know another one because I start
I mean look we there are only 70 or
whatever the number were of us in 79 and
80 and we really had the mortar and the
bricks and we just stayed there that's
why I get through the day name the
studio laughter you and Tommy and I hope
they do something for Tommy me I hope
that they name the newsroom I've been
trying to get that behind the scenes
where I judge now it's not anymore but I
just want them to acknowledge Tommy's
and you and Bob Lee because without you
guys everybody wants work there now but
without you guys it wouldn't exist well
that's nice you to say it would but it
was a great idea we happen to be Bob and
Tommy was a couple years older Bob and I
are at the same age within a couple
months so we were 24 and we're
completely different people as you know
but but total respect I mean Bob Lee I
mean he keeps us honest you see us yeah
I don't know if that the same can be
said of me or when you guys were there
I'm playing now but you're too kind in
that but explain this to me though Chris
we got when I was observing another
members of Charlotte Observer yeah
you're like I was in Charlotte Observer
and I go yeah you got a nickname before
you write this I appreciate what that
was not everybody can say that okay but
you know in the newsroom there where you
had off the wall of monitors yes not
explaining to me this
there'd be a game in a game a game a
game in a game of the game in a game in
a game and then porn well not so I
didn't have the Bob Gore board I didn't
you know who had the clicker Tim Brando
see now hi well yeah and I thought okay
I can either prefer an organized no I
don't I bet there was nothing it's not
like you think it at whatever it was
like a manual or something like that
right Fritzi you know that that's
exactly with me yeah the way with that
was
it was a little loud Wild West like
though well look we were it was still in
the age when hey look the Royals game is
on tonight I got every team down and
solder be a Wednesday night in the mid
to late 80s yeah and maybe five teams
had their midweek game on New York or
Boston was always on but that hey we got
the ring loosely the Padres yeah a
positive ion a Giants it's coming in and
it was just kind of it was still really
are we still here you know wish there
were still a little sense of wonderment
that's the right word but I don't know
if we knew who was watching well but
I'll tell you as you found out very
quickly and you probably did before you
came over to us that you'd run into
people in odd places actually early in
my career that's when I because I did
the 230 with first three but the 230
show and I remember being out on the
west coast and and early 80's and you
sit down to eat and the waiter would
come over and say so what does the Swami
want to drink what are you talking about
like this is early eighties
oh they're watching out west so you I
get great letters and this is long
before married the kabuna kids I mean
from husbands in Iowa thank goodness
you're on because at 2:00 a.m. when I'm
feeding the baby I'm watching your show
yeah and I'm thinking who would get up
at 2:00 o'clock in the morning to feed
the baby like what what is this an
Unser's but it's back then you got
letters to kind of inform you what was
going on so you never know my message to
everyone coming to our place now there's
somebody watching somewhere that it
could be big time could be little time
you're making an impression on you don't
know why or where they are but they're
there Paulie did you get in trouble I've
always wanted to tell you this Chris
I actually got put in detention in
eighth grade guy who does you when used
to do Joaquin the dog Andujar we all
loved you I it was in a history class
and I made a joke of the answers I put
Abraham and cheese Lincoln and I got
detention that day invention and I said
it was because I watch school or college
eighth grade Oh eighth grade College I'm
worried about you but eighth grade man
I'm proud of it he ate that that's very
good I mean you could go George Carr
Washington you could do whatever you I
never quite did that when I majored in
history of brown I didn't quite do that
although we did have nicknames at the
time but thank you for that my pleasure
we're going to look up who that teacher
was and re-educated Chris will be
hosting Espeon special post season NFL
countdown that will be at 11 a.m.
Eastern and then a NFL primetime and so
the NFL primetime is know okay okay I'm
just an interval
moving forward it'll seem like whoa that
the fall is completely different because
as you know you can't say we'll do the
football show week one three eight ten
that will fit into my no no you're
swimming in the deep end or you're not
yeah but I'm going to do the Super Bowl
prime times from the field moving
forward the do championship game prime
time so no go they'll be still some
highlights and I'll be around just not
as prevalent if that's the right word I
mean you've got glasses on you know
prevalent I can say that I can see and
it'll be different in the fall but
honestly I will say this because up
until September not that much as good at
you're not doing the draft that's okay
I'm not doing homerun Derby
that's okay not that I don't but it's it
that's okay so but now September comes
are going to kick it off I'm going to
remind myself what I was at twenty
aspiring to cover pro football and be
Brent at 62 when I'm Sunday Ticket and
this I don't have to relearn why I like
it but I'll watch like the consumer that
I was 40 years ago
yeah and I'm okay I'm okay there I'll
miss the action I'll miss being in the
middle but I I still love football and I
never showered on my job and but it's
okay
forty years ago I've carried the ball 35
times
aim for 40 years I'll see you next year
at this time if you'd like
Chris Berman I don't know if there's an
easy way to say but other than thank you
thank you you're welcome and thank you
thanks Ann I will come back the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
[Music]